[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys
appreciate y'all for coming through man
right now i'm alone
as you can see
there's no one here i got someone coming
in here in a little bit
so you know i figured i'd go ahead and
do this by myself until that individual
shows up
so first thing
i want to talk about
is zelda because i feel like that's the
only thing that really doesn't appeal
to anything going on here
hold up am i having issues with the
stream
doesn't look like it
this is the audio current bitrate is
lower than record okay if you guys have
issues in the stream just just tell me
hold on let me fix something real quick
my throat's doing a little bit better
it's still a little sore
all right all right so let me fix that a
little bit
so is something wrong with the audio
chat you got to inform me man you got to
inform me now i'm good all right so
so let's
let's talk about
skyward sword
all right so
those of you that know
you know me
and you know me and
and king argue about this game
constantly we argue about it all the
time every time it comes up
so i played it again and i i forgot a
lot about it this game
but
i like the temples
you know after replaying the game after
so many years i could see you know
especially after breath of the wild you
guys know how i feel about breath of the
wild breath of the wild was a good game
it just wasn't
a good zelda game if that makes sense to
to you guys
and i think that was the biggest
thing to me it was
look we got this game called breath of
the wild
and to be honest with you breath of the
wild didn't feel like
like a zelda game it felt like i'm a
little bit low
i'm a little bit low
all right all right so maybe that will
fix things a little bit
we've got to upgrade those
uh about we have to upgrade these mics
to you guys we about to about to take it
to the next level
one second
all right all right
so
i do enjoy skyred sword
from that aspect that it's a it's more
like an actual zelda game than than
breath of the wild
but
we gotta talk about it
this combat
might be some of the worst combat i've
played in video game history
and i'm not exaggerating when i say that
like i really mean that
video game
history
it is so
bad
whoever decided to make this
i don't know what you were thinking
i don't know why you did what you did
it's just like come on man like
we don't need
this this motion stuff at all
like this motion stuff is
is horrible
and i feel like
to me
they completely missed that
skyward sword i'm enjoying the world
kinda you know where they open up spots
throughout the map
but as far as that that's all i could
really think of
now it's like i said it's not a bad game
but it just is one of those things where
it's like
the combat is so bad
that i'm just like
maybe it's time to find something else
you know and
i'm curious to hear your guys's thought
on it too to be honest with you because
i know some of you play zelda some of
you don't some of you only really plays
uh you know
some of you
very diverse group of people man
very diverse group of people and i'm
curious you know is that something that
when it comes to zelda
is that something that when in terms of
the 3ds like which ones were your
favorite
the
legend of zelda
which
was your favorite
if i might
if i misspell stuff
i don't care
ocarina of time
oh my god
majuro's mask
we'll put skyward sword
and
breath
of the wild
some ask that community that real quick
you know get a little bit of feedback
from you guys man find out exactly
what's going on with that yeah i'm still
a little bit sore just a little bit but
i'm able to talk and that's all that
matters i'm able to talk
now keep in mind
for the people in the chat
you don't have to put
skyward sword
you don't you could easily put something
else
you don't have to put skyward wind waker
i wish i could have fit that on there i
like twilight princess
i like twilight princess
there's just so many good ones
it's just we couldn't really go into all
of them because they only give us four
slots
can't really do stuff when they only
give us four slots so we have to we have
to go what we have been we have to go
what we have
so
man
i'm uh majuro's mask is underrated
um hate nintendo so done
gotta drink that tea with lemon honey my
guy what does that mean gotta drink that
tea with lemon
i'm confused on that one man i'm
confused on that one
they had to feed into the gimmick for
the console yeah i think that's
that's the main culprit here
i think that's the main culprit here is
they had to feed into the gimmick
and they had to
make sure that it used what they
promoted it as and i think the combat
suffered greatly because of it
as all the best gaming moments majora's
mask i don't know about that man i don't
know if pedro's mask has all the best
gaming moments breath of water is the
war zelda game it's not bad but i have a
hard time connecting with it that's what
i'm saying like what makes zelda zelda
to me is absent in breath of the wild
breath of the wild is a good game no
one's going to take that away from it
but to me
it just doesn't look like a zelda game
it doesn't feel like a zelda game
why didn't you type about br
why didn't you like it oh that's that's
what i was saying christopher
i i'm not saying that was bad
oh you put put the crest in the chat man
i don't have the uh unfortunately
i don't have access and i don't know if
if i can even switch
it might cut the
the podcast i need to bring the emotes
to this one i do need to do that
now i'm not even risking it man we ain't
shutting this down because i don't know
how obs works
and it's like i said that is my only
real gripe when it comes to this you
know when it comes to it is i just feel
like
they wanted to innervate so much when it
come to zelda make it so big make you
could climb anything but
they they completely forgot what made
zelda zelda like to me
you know temples is one of the biggest
things to zelda it's one of the things
that's always made what zelda is
and to me they failed that they cared
too much more about how zelda fell uh
how zelda you could climb every mountain
you know you and i felt like the world
in breath of the wild wasn't really that
that big either i felt like you know
they could have it definitely improved
on that as well
the lord's emails are here lord i know
you guys have them i don't you know how
like
cognito will be able to put the actual
emotes that you guys put in the chat up
on the screen i don't have access to
those in the
the one that i'm in like how it goes is
obs
you could go you can that you could
switch profiles i have a profile i've
made a profile for addict world and
there's a profile for the iron lord's
podcast that's why the outlayer of mine
is different and i do you know
let a little bit of time go by we are
going to be improving a little bit in
terms of the added world and how exactly
it looks and presents like i do have my
own thought process to how i want the
addicts world to
so you know i want to keep that in mind
all right so my do uh
so my guest should be coming here any
minute
probably here in the next 10 minutes
let me go ahead and
share this on twitter real quick
and if you guys want to you can always
share it on twitter that would be nice
get some sharing on twitter going on
oh
right there we go
now let me go to the iron lures podcast
let me share this too
now one of the reasons i'm doing this i
mean i could have easily got a third
person
and just had him in here first but i do
want to get a little bit more
comfortable talking by myself
and just you know bouncing off the chat
because i feel like that is a really
unique skill to be able to use
so i feel like uh you know i need to
start working on that a little bit
so it looks like right now ocarina of
time is winning by law
and that's the stuff that i'll be saying
like i do feel like
breath of the wild gets all this hype
because people
don't remember what zelda was when these
other ones
is my mic low like i don't know man like
hold up i will turn it up all the way
but if it's too loud
it's not my fault man if it's too loud
it's not my fault
i cannot help if this mic is loud now
you guys have spoke about it being too
low
i maxed that to the max man
we got a 10 super chat from lady sand
dropping some support your way addict i
appreciate all the support you guys
i definitely appreciate it
my mic is kind of low like
how's that better is that better let me
look at my volumes man i feel like i'm
going to make this too loud like
i feel like i'm going to make this too
too loud
all right so i probably just made it too
loud i'ma be real with you i probably
just made it too loud you guys probably
just messed me up man because there's a
little bit of delay between the stream
and here and i literally just raised it
so it's probably going to be loud now
we felt abandoned without you on sunday
look man i was not feeling well my voice
is still still kind of messed up
and maybe it's like
i need to to stop
i don't know like sometimes i get a
little bit too much into into the into
the podcasting scene
and i will
i talk too loud or something or you know
i'll be too aggressive which i get a lot
of feedback that i'm too aggressive and
it's not something that like
i can't turn it off like i try i can't
turn it off
it's just like even if i tone it down
i end up going right back at it like
it's it's not something that i could
just turn off but you know i need to be
a little bit more laid back in terms of
the
of the podcast that way you know my
voice doesn't get destroyed
because i feel like i've been in too
much stuff whether it's discord
or the podcast or attic show or
streaming or making my own videos that
my voice just is constantly being worked
on over and over again
quit yelling at people and you'd be good
look dallas
that's just how it is man it's just how
it is
that
that is my style and that's for the most
part you know
what's up the abandon you know we could
talk about that real quick
hold up
and it's not that
that's being me because it is being me
but i do feel like i could improve that
like i don't feel like i have to be that
aggressive all the time
and you know
i because i get so into the podcast we
gotta find out superchat from gerald
mack just showing support for the iop
all hell the iop shout out to the lords
i definitely appreciate the uh super
chat hold up
we about we about to talk about this
abandoned stuff man because it's
interesting
is
abandoned out what
okay hold up
so there's that one
so i'm curious on your guys do you
really think
that
this game abandoned is being made by
kojima
and if you see i said that man because i
don't know how to spell kojima i'm not
even attempting it
i'm not butchering his name
so
yes
no
i think
i don't know part of me feels like
part of me feels like
they would be stupid
for it not to be working with kojima at
this point they've been so vocal about
talking with kojima it's so vocal about
hinting kojima maybe not talking with
kojima but hinting with kojima that i'm
just like if they're not working with
them
and if he's not part of this project
it's going to be really bad
like i don't think the game is going to
survive
there was supposed to be something that
popped up on um
hold up
all right so let's
let's go over it man let's go over it
here
abandoned uh two dollars subscribe from
playing my band is a con artist don't
even at me
man people go ah flame in that chat adam
you have to we got to pull up on flame
adam at flame in that chat you don't
have to say no just at flame in that
chat man
at flame okay so let's go over this a
little bit
let's see what the community thinks
let's click latest
abandon oh hold up
let me um
fix this
there we
go
all right so let's
come happy
it's all jokes man it's all jokes we we
we ain't trying to to attack flame it's
all jokes so let's let's go over some of
these that's going on with the kojima
game named abandon all right so
obviously i've searched abandoned ps5
so you know questions uh let's translate
the tweet
the other question abandons generally
went from being intriguing to being
bored to being ridiculous how
interesting this reveal has not yet
abandoned and what's funny is we don't
even know nothing about this game yet
we don't know anything about this game
in the fact that it's got this much
what's what i'm looking for this much
attention
i feel like it's bad in in itself
because as of right now we don't know
nothing about this game
if it does turn out that he is working
with the company
it might it's definitely going to help
it a lot of people say this is silent
hill i do know that
um
the people who make what is that company
called the people who made um
medium
i don't know what that company's called
but i'm pretty sure they're working on
silent hill now
there could be multiple companies
working on silent hill
because i know that they're really big
on licensing their their stuff right now
but to me i just don't know if they're
actually working let me make sure that
homeboy isn't showing up no he hasn't
showed up yet all right
uh two dollar super chat for flame might
uh
knight might make a video about this
it's a con
definitely understand that man uh i i
encourage everyone you know try to get
into the into the content creator stream
a little bit like you know you don't
have to take it seriously sometimes i
let this content creator thing get to me
a little bit well if you know not
necessarily like the viewership on my
personal channel or the growth on iop
because everyone wants to have some
growth
and sometimes i let that get to me too
much
and i try not to but it's it's really
hard to not let that get to you the
blooper team i appreciate you guys man
you guys are always looking out for me
the blooper team i'm pretty sure they're
working on silent hill but it might not
be that might be multiple teams working
on silent hill
but the thing is like no one knows this
studio like i don't think anyone knows
what this studio is so
like how would they get their hands on
it like are they going to pay for that
i don't know we'll have to see man we'll
have to see it's interesting it's
interesting
but i mean look at these people talking
on here like
the trailer got delayed because kojima
is still working on laugh out loud
abandon like they're literally the
laughingstock right now
they're the laughing stock of the
internet right now like to me if they're
not working with kojima
is this is this all that's even worth it
that's what i'm like is is any of this
even worth it if they are working with
kojima if they're not working with
kojima
because if they're not working with
kojima
they can literally just
they could stop the bleeding now they
don't have to go to this extra stuff
anymore
and i think that's like the biggest
thing here man it's like we got
is working with kuji not working with
kojima worth all of this pr
where if they aren't working the kojima
at the end of the day they're gonna get
destroyed and i think that's my biggest
question
is is that worth this much pr if they're
not working with kojima and and to me if
they're not working with kojima
they wouldn't let it get this big they
would have shut this down a long time
ago
silent hill blooper team might be at
xbox timed exclusive you might be right
uh because they they do normally work
with
them people so it is interesting you
know
so let's get back to the
so
is the abandoned app malware should i
delete it from my ps5 i didn't know it
was a ps5 app i thought it was a phone
app i might have to look at that i
didn't know it was a ps5 app
the trailer got delayed because kojima
is still working on it
see this is how you know when stuff gets
like really really public is when i see
other languages talking about because
gaming is everywhere
but
for my particular side of twitter i
don't see it too much
so it's it's kind of interesting man i'm
really interesting to see exactly where
this turns out from
now
you know i don't think kojima's really
commented on this like at all
so it's gonna be interesting to see what
he has to say as well
yes i mean it's it's kind of crazy it's
kind of crazy
alright so let's go ahead
my guest should be getting here any
minute now he said 5 30.
now
let's talk about a little bit about
the xbox giveaway more upgrades or xbox
at gamescom
because my
my guest
is everborn
so i'm curious what you guys want me to
talk about when he gets here like which
topic which topic do you guys want to
speak of man the the xbox at gamescom
first or do you want to speak about the
hellblade upgrades and how good xbox has
been doing with that particular line of
sight kind of curious to get you guys
opinion on that
and you know what one thing i do want to
ask you guys is
what exactly kind of guests do you guys
want on the attic show
what kind of guest do you guys want on
the attic show
guys can definitely uh
keep me updated man what kind of guests
do you guys want on here
gotta know gotta know
so i mean
gamescom i mean we could talk about
gamescom first
i don't mind talking about gamescom
first
so gamescom
you know we'll go ahead and get into it
while we wait for uh
homeboy
sorry man someone beat you to it man
someone beat you to it
gamescom
xbox and gamescom trying to get that
article
i think this is it
yeah this is it
this is the article
optimus do you guys really want to see
optimus code on here
octavius is my dude but i know a lot of
you like don't necessarily like
you know uh
kind of like the back and forth stuff
you guys just like
just re just pretty much like talking
about xbox and i know if i bring optimus
on here there's going to be a lot of
back and forth because of you know some
of his opinions and i'll you know if
that's the type of
entertainment that you guys want
periodically i wouldn't do that every
week
but i would uh i would i would do that
just to get people's mindset keep in
mind some of these people they tr they
troll on twitter that's not who they
really are like optimus
does if he came on my show he wouldn't
he wouldn't be trolling like he does on
twitter
he does that just just to pass the time
man he's not really like that kind of
person but you know what we'll see what
comes about it man we'll see what comes
about it
well i promise if i ever did bring
optimus on this show
it wouldn't it wouldn't be what you guys
think
i kind of like pick his brain on how he
got this kind of thought process down
some of the stuff he'd be saying
that that's how i would probably do it i
wonder if he's in the chat
no he's not in the chat
but so let's talk about
literally optimus is a troll
he is a troll
and he he really does do a little bit
too much on twitter but he's not a bad
dude you guys like he's not a bad dude
he's just
hey bro
i invite myself get me on bro
i would bring you on don
gino patelli i don't know how to
pronounce your name i have you have to
forgive myself is that something that
you guys would be up to like
occasionally what i would do is have
like an open discord where you know
there would be a waiting room for you
guys and i could just drag you in here
and we could talk would that be
something you guys would be open for i
don't know how many people in this chat
would feel like they want to talk
like people don't realize that's why you
see like a lot of guests when they go
onto a show
that's why you see a lot of them
generally don't talk a lot when they go
onto a podcast because it's different
being in the chat than it is talking in
the actual podcast so that's why i'm
like curious to hear you guys opinion on
if that's something that you would even
really want to see
uh did you watch the idea twitter show
no i didn't was there anything good
oh my god you guys are ridiculous
if you bring octopus code on the show
i'd have to get it to prove through the
retirement home he's saying that
oh my god
you guys be coming out with those uh
those old jokes don't you i don't really
have to uh much to say myself
that's what i'm saying like
maybe on your own channel but on the
iron lords uh yeah you probably got a
point there daniel that's why if i'd
ever did it all it would be on this show
but i would just be letting anyone in
here like you would be you'd be vetted
before you just gotta got into the
actual
room that i'm in i wouldn't just let you
in here
you need joe biden as a kid look man
if i could get the president of the
united states
on the podcast
i think i mean i don't even know what i
would talk to joe biden about
but i think it would definitely be like
an interesting conversation like what
would i ever talk about this man
like am i just gonna
you know talk about the pandemic
how it's affecting the gaming industry
like that that would be a funny
conversation give me a always i'm under
the iron lore's podcast name right now
so if you're like trying to tag me
uh i'm under this
this account
you have to attack that account
it's best to vet people first yeah i
would never just let someone in here
you'd get vetted i would probably have
someone
in the actual room talking to people
and then they would drag them if
they seem cool
i'm all about interesting guests i do
enjoy when they're tired tied to the
topic
tell them to speed up the chips what you
talking about man you talk about the
guests like i actually have to see if
he's not waiting
to come in
no he's still not waiting okay
see i can't see the actual i can't see
the the screen that i i need to look
about the setting to just let people
join
ask him does he game
he get he games he games i could tell
you guys right now that octopus called
games
any female game par podcaster
uh i do know a couple
uh i knew erica
i know a couple of streamers
but you know besides erica because the
streamers they just play like you know
their set set of games i don't think
they really keep up with the industry
like i would expect the majority of this
chat to so i don't think that they would
be a good fit for podcasting because
they wouldn't know what a lot of the
stuff we're talking about is but i'm
sure there's a lot of female you know
gamers in our community
the ashton luca podcast ashton luca i
definitely she knows what's going on she
knows what's up
she knows exactly what's up man
man i don't know why twitter be youtube
be messing up sometimes like sometimes
it'd be crashing and then coming up
ashland luca i could get ash and luca on
here that wouldn't be too complicated me
and ash and luke
are cool
talking about joe pi
i don't know why people are talking
about joe biden man that was a joke man
it was a joke
you guys are being too much man you guys
are being too much
uh let me
check on my guests
i think next time that you know the
guest i have is delayed
might just delay the podcast in general
i don't know like like i said i'm trying
to get better at just talking to a
screen because sometimes it's hard for
me to not bounce off of people when i
talk i can do this but i do feel like i
can improve in it drastically but i just
i need to improve on it
when phil uh showing up on the iron
lords look
i will tell you guys that we do
we do have a guest list
though spencer's currently not on that
guest list but
you know we we're trying man we're
trying
you know if you guys want phil spencer
on the podcast man go on twitter
tag phil spencer
what and say phil spencer i would love
for you to be on the iron lords podcast
tag the iron lords podcast you know
because if you show
if you show interest and you show people
the people want where he want where he
needs to be
you know my it might get him it might
get microsoft reaching out to us
you don't know how it goes like that man
that might end up happening microsoft
reaches out to us
and they're like yo we would really like
to come on the show because people keep
tagging us in this show we got to get
this popping and i think that would be
interesting but it's like i said i don't
know
dude's a busy man he's a busy man he
might not have enough time to come on
the iron lures podcast right now
but you know maybe we'll have him on in
the next year because what we are you
know we we do have a better relationship
with microsoft than we did
probably this time last year
so there is a chance that he might come
on in the future
phil spencer hears xbox podcasts
if helps to someone fill in the gaps and
go back and forth with it does and i
think people don't understand that
when you have someone that you can
bounce off of it's a lot easier to talk
to people
but like you know
that that's why i'm trying to get better
because i i kind of i'm interested in
streaming
so i'm trying to get better on just you
know talking with my community by myself
without necessarily another person
around either
i think that's the main reason for this
man
flame i can guess for a little if you
want you know what flame are you in our
discord flame are you on our discord
are you in our discord because flame is
a member i trust flame if blade wants to
come through
and bounce back and forth while i wait
for my guest let me make sure my guest
is actually
not here he's not
you know what would do that we'll do
that that's fine man
we'll do that i need twitter first what
do you mean you need twitter first
oh you need to make a twitter first
i get you man i get you
all right so
all right so what i've done
uh you're a writer uh go ahead and join
the ad
join um
join the
one of the public
okay join one of the public's one of the
public discords and tell me when you're
there and i will drag you into the attic
world
on fire lost forever
and you know what we'll talk about
one of these topics while we wait for
for a
homeboy to show up he should be coming
up here any minute he's got got a
meeting man he's got a job you know he's
got got to feed the families
on fire
some of your guys's names has always
been crazy to me a dog with a saxophone
that's funny
um
silk slayer
i've always liked silk slayer it's
always been interesting
so we are climbing close to getting
the
the monetization uh about the
monetization the the the little man i
know you guys really like the emotes
uh so we are coming close on that let me
double check
where we're at right now
because you guys have been really good
to us
uh you know we we are we're only like
three members away from
what's up meds
meds if you want man you could pull up
too
it's cool i'm waiting for people mans
i'm waiting for people
you could pull up two meds evening from
the uk
the uk
i'm interested
to find out where the people
that follow the show are from
so so put
put in the chat where you're listening
to this from i want to see the
origination of some of the individual
people that follow the podcast
podcast in general even
and keep in mind flame when you're ready
put it in the actual chat because i'm
not paying attention to discord
currently
so put it in the actual chat
put it in the actual chat
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens at gamescom
so we got a new jersey
we got a canada
we got a texas
cali
east coast new jersey texas india
florida
uk wisconsin uh the tidally i probably
just butchered that my b man
probably just butchered that the
philippines
uh new york city we got uh meds homeboys
uh he moved to new jersey germany
northern ireland uk
the na in the miami i don't know where n
a is i don't know geography like that i
should probably learn
cali in the u.s
i've been to california a couple times
it's a nice little place
oregon
south carolina florida massachusetts
i got a friend actually lives up in
massachusetts
the uk has listened to iop when in ter
uh but have listened i put one was in
turkey and and georgie
virginia in the building i i live in
virginia jason b that's what's up new
york city but i live in pennsylvania now
i i see people are leaving new york city
by like the truckloads
it's like the
new york city just
a bad place to live these days maybe
it's like the high rent they have
because i know their rent's like
ridiculous
damn bro for us from jersey there's a
lot of you from jersey man
there's a lot of you from jersey the
caribbean's washington california
jersey represents man
like there's too many of you from jersey
man there's too many of you from jersey
too many
i left in 2005 the cost
yeah i i've been told the cost is pretty
bad there
up until the cost is pretty bad there
attic would you classify yourself as a
re
see i don't want to answer that because
i don't exactly know what you mean by
that so i'm a i'm a google that
see
it's only the only thing popping up is
dogs
so i feel like that's a that's a
question made to make me look bad
and i feel like you might be a troll but
i don't know
oh you pinged me
i don't know what a ping is
just join any of the discords that's in
the uh the
the iron uh
that's in the actual
stream like that's in the actual discord
just join any of those
just join any of those and i will drag
you in
uh atlantic city i'm uh
oh
so he should uh
my guest should be here now
what's up everborn
what's happening what's happening what's
happening nothing much i was just
talking to the folks while we was
waiting for you
oh man i feel special
you're fine man so they they want to
talk about
xbox at gamescom first but since you're
here i think the best point of action
because i've already talked about the
skyrid sword i don't know if you have
too much to talk about skyrosaur do you
you know i never played it because it
first came out on wii u right the wii u
that is the only nintendo console that i
did not own after the super nintendo
because i never had i never had a
regular s uh nes
and uh
i'll never forget that i felt like i was
tortured as a child for not having that
but that's that's neither here nor there
that that's what's up uh flame
do you have a twitter i'ma get you in
here too
if you have a twitter but um yeah
so first thing like i think he does have
a twitter
i don't know i i looked it up
sometimes it's
sometimes it's hard to find people
that's in youtube on twitter because
like their handles are different than
their names see this is what i'm saying
man i keep i k asante i had to i had to
shame him into uh updating all of his uh
handles everywhere it's all about
branding man you got to keep it
consistent across the board
i keep everyone saga on everything
okay it's like hot sauce
it's like hot sauce yeah
put that on everything
yeah sometimes that that's a little hard
though
oh man just change it i i i
i think what it is
is like some of them
are hard to actually like that name to
be open
because like on xbox
i'm lord addict with a bunch of numbers
and i don't like that
but there's nothing i can do about that
like hold up like the numbers are like
four two six eight or something like
that it's the craziest stuff i've ever
seen but when they said that you can
change your name and you'll have that
number thing to my knowledge it made
they made it seem like your those
numbers would only appear certain times
you know what i'm saying
yeah
but then when i actually like looked
into it
they were every time everywhere
hey let me ask you a question completely
complete change of subject however
what is going on with it ben
what's up going on joe it's flame from
the chat man it's flame from the chat
flame what's happening what's happening
nice to meet you everborn so so so what
was you saying everybody abandoned what
is this [ __ ] show this oh yeah we was we
was actually just talking about that
so right now
everborn tell me yes sir gun to your
head is ever born being worked on by
kojima
no comments
[Laughter]
did i do it right yeah i don't know i i
i'm gonna wrap an article real quick
give me a second everborn confirms
kojima
so so what's going on uh flame uh so so
what are you what's your opinions on the
whole abandon issue
well there's been a lot of videos i've
been surfacing of people that have been
using the way back machine
on the internet more or less
look at blue box's website and what
they've been doing prior to abandoned
ads announcements
and uh
look
i wish for the best for this developer i
really do
but at the same time there's a long
history of him just releasing like very
broken unreal engine builds
and putting them out onto steam to die
more or less
i don't think that's gonna happen to
abandon because he actually
has to look good to playstation on this
you know in this situation but uh
i have no faith in that and it's
definitely not silent hill and i'm tired
of hearing that it's silent hill
no no it's uh it's a metal gear now you
didn't see the last
apparently um you know people think he's
working on
uh metal gear with blue
then they think he's working on
silent hill with the abandoned
developers then they think he's he's
working on the actual game he's working
on what that got canceled the stadio
so i'm just like you guys
just just admit that you're wrong that's
all you have to do just admit that
you're wrong
they can't but but but furthermore i
really think this is just
what happens because of sort of sony's
marketing style of silence right they
don't they really don't say anything
until they have something concrete to
announce and they let their fans kind of
you know roughly through let's be real
they let them go wild
yes
yes they do
and and i noticed
there was a lot of smoke for a a free
update yesterday
and those same people with all that
smoke
no smoke for this but
maybe their business maybe that maybe
their work today like here's my thing
and i've said it multiple times
i will be on microsoft to make better
games i'll be on
uh sony to to make better features but i
don't
expect one to not do it because the
other one's doing it better
i'm like i want them both to improve
both of the features i want i want
everyone to improve everything like mike
playstation just think about it you they
literally just announced that you have
to pay ten dollars to activate ps5
features a couple weeks ago to a month
ago that's crazy and then
like a week later after that or two
weeks later after that they announced
that they're having a beta for hardware
if this was flipped around ign would
have 10 articles about it gamespot would
have 10 articles about it every podcast
will be talking about it every week
but because it's sony let's let's let's
briefly talk about it let's let's have a
passing topic let's let's let's have
like a drive-by topic we're like yeah
that's bull they just walk right out the
door and i just i just i feel like
sometimes man
microsoft they're in such a uphill
battle that there's nothing they can do
well i think honestly
what i think it comes down to is
i think we don't get to have the adult
conversations about things until
um
sony does a thing right
a lot of the times you'll see microsoft
do a thing and it's a five alarm fire
this is the end of all this is the end
of days you know what i mean the um
this is it it's over it's bad for the
industry but if there's a delay on the
sony side they say well delays are good
right if there is something like this
beta
um ssd thing
they say well it's not that bad and you
have to think about it this way in that
way right and so we get very logical
when it comes on to those things
but the same uh
the same logic is not applied
uh
in in the other direction
right and i just wish we could
um
have adult conversations no matter what
uh side of uh uh
we fall on with these things right like
i think i think we should we should be
able to debate
in good faith
instead of um
you know uh my my platform good your
platform that i think the biggest issue
that we have
is like you said like fanboys don't want
to admit the other ones wrong like for
instance do you know how much this chat
and i'm talking to you people in the
chat i don't know which ones are you
but how many people attacked me because
all i said is i wanted more from
starfield that's all i said
oh my god you would think that i said
the whole show was trash that nothing
they showed was good i literally said i
understand why they did it i was just
disappointed and oh
my
god i was having people message me on
twitter saying that i'm wrong i was
having people
adding me on twitter saying that i was
wrong but then
the same people was like attic you write
about the the ps5 unlock features you
should be talking about this and i'm
like look man
you will never see me
hold my tongue for something that i want
from something
like sure some of you
have this concept that you know
we should have to talk about everything
that's anti-consumer or quote-unquote
depending on what you feel is
anti-consumer
and then
it's not how it works i'm only going to
talk about stuff that i'm passionate
about i don't care about the rest
like for instance killer instinct
doesn't it looks like they're looking
but it's not out there
i don't care about killer instinct
you're not going to see me
do 10 minute 15 minute videos i can
sympathize with you know the k-megas
that want that game but me personally
i couldn't care less
so let's let's go to joe real quick joe
first off let's let's
round this back a little bit
all right let's talk about hellblade
getting its new update so and first off
everborn didn't you love how the
playstation people didn't get that
because yo let me tell you oh my god joe
i
was an anti-consumer
i was in some of these uh twitter spaces
where they were having cry sessions
about this oh yeah this is i was
actually i was told about these i was
told
this is the whole like that they got
together because they didn't get it
that's what it's about you know how i
know that and i'm this is not hyperbole
this is nothing
there was none of this smoke
for um
what's it called um a plague's tale you
know why
because both of them got it
as soon as they didn't get something
just like with psychonauts 2
that's when that's when it's trash now
because they didn't get it
right and at the end of the day
i think all you see all of this right
it's because
okay
return came out
not for me but a lot of people liked it
like 560 000 people liked it and then
and then ratchet came out
but i think the same way a lot of
uh xbox guys have to live by that power
sword and die by that power sword the
people who were talking about that i
wasn't one of those people um
i think the playstation guys have to
live and die by that aaa exclusive sword
because there's nothing coming out for
the rest of the year
and they got nothing to talk about and
they're watching all of these games
they're watching death's door they're
watching the ascent they're watching
these things that they're not getting
and they told you
for
i don't know how since the beginning of
the generation before that but i'm
concerned with this generation that you
have no gains
and now by their logic because you kept
trying to talk sense into them there's a
lot of things to play there's a lot of
things to do it's not all about that you
know the kind of game sony makes and now
they have no games to play by their
standards and so now they're crying so
and the tears are delicious
so
so joe was the tears delicious to you
was you was you gone blowing them up how
did you feel when you heard that
how did you feel when hellblade was
announced i was getting an update keep
in mind chat i've never played hellblade
i've tried a couple times uh it kind of
messes with me mentally a little bit
because of like i don't like i don't
like hearing people talk in my ears like
that like it creeps me out but i think
i'ma try it because of this update now
joe
what did you feel like when you
initially heard the the announcement
that they were getting this update and
and what did you feel like when the
actual
news that sony wasn't getting the same
treatment do you feel like that was like
maybe anti-consumer
well i mean i joked about the whole
anti-consumer saying but at the same
time we do have to look at the fact that
yes hellblade did actually launch on
playstation 4 xbox i can understand that
people who
bought so uh sending a sacrifice on ps4
and now they have a ps5 they would since
they did support ninja theory back then
they would like to see that update i do
actually understand that
standpoint the thing that i don't
understand what where's my sunset
overdrive update
did they did did that happen for ps5 did
he get did he get it
it did not i think would would but no
one's expecting it yeah i think what
he's saying is since they own
uh insomniac no one's expecting a sunset
overdrive update on xbox well yeah but
at the same time sensitive drivers never
actually put on to the playstation
though um
i think the
i think the thought process is that
so
playstation 4 got senua's sacrifice
first we supported it
which they did kind of i don't know
exactly how many copies got sold and i'm
not really too concerned on that front
but um
they supported it they now have ps5s
they would like to get this update
considering they did kind of support it
but it's only going to be given to the
xbox side because
one i think they're basically testing
that build to
update it for the steam and game pass pc
versions because that's not updated
on that side so
it's kind of messy i kind of understand
some of the mentalities but people
looking at the ray trace gets saying oh
it doesn't look that good or something
like that that that's what i'm just like
oh come on you're just you're just
hating for no reason
so
i appreciate i actually love the update
i played a little bit of it yesterday it
was awesome and
yeah
that was kind of all over the place but
that's because there's so much going on
with it but for everybody's thing i do
understand
where ray's come from on the sunset
overdrive side but that's
but we'll cross that bridge whenever i
guess sunset overdrive gets put onto
playstation 5 and is updated
to have 4k 60 ray tracing all that kind
of stuff and then it'll be like okay
yeah where is it for xbox because that
would be
i get what you're saying you're pretty i
just think no one would expect that
though and that's that's my issue no
like that if that happened everyone
would be surprised
even the xbox guys
like
yeah it would be expected but at the
same time it's just like
some people that did support it
in the very beginning they would like to
at least feel like they were appreciated
back then because
with xbox you can just download send you
a sacrifice and get that update for free
no charge no nothing whatsoever so so
that's kind of my stance on this so
pretty much your thought process is like
look like
it should happen but at the same time
like the reason that the circumstances
and situations are different is because
one was a multi-plat before the
companies bought and the other one was
always an exclusive so one makes more
sense than the other okay so here's my
opinion all right
at the end of the day
i've always had this concept uh you know
even when it came to
what was the last thing this happened to
uh psychonauts 2. i was never going to
play psychonauts 2 really you know
but
to me
those people
if you want them to come to your
platform you might as well give them the
best project they possibly can have
so that you know if they so when they
play psychonauts 2 they're like yo this
is great
and they're like oh the studio is an
xbox only game studio now well obviously
pc now i got to buy an xbox to keep up
with this with this the studio so to me
it feels like you know i don't like
using this war but i'm gonna use it
gimping the version over there is going
to hurt that the prod is gonna hurt the
the thought process and the product over
there because not everyone playing
psychonauts 2 is going to be
an everborn a joe or an addict where we
know
the reasoning behind making that version
worse
i don't think it was necessarily
microsoft intentionally wanted to make
that version worse i think microsoft
just got to the point where they're like
why are we going to spend money to make
a version the same as our other as our
version when we don't need to do that we
we are only really obligated to make the
ps4 version we're not obligated to make
the ps5 version and i'm okay with that
but at the same time i'm like
you could have potentially got more
people over there to get an xbox because
they wanted to keep up with you know
take two would not take too
double fine so but at the end of the day
it's like you know you could reverse
that
just because not everyone would know
that
that's the situation that's going on
with uh double fine
not everyone's gonna know double fine
even makes that game
so you know and let's be real here
psychonauts 2 is going to be a fun game
to a lot of people but i don't think
it's going to be that game you know what
i'm saying so
i can understand i could see it from
both ways i got a super chat real quick
we got a five dollar sweep shot from bay
area
we were just talking about where people
are coming is isn't that a place
somewhere bay area
like i don't know
i think that's
there's a lot of basin
see see i i live in a small town of
virginia all right so
uh this is actually directed towards you
everborn evermore notice nobody cried
for dubroter's free update either
because both consoles got it
yep that's it that's exactly what it is
they just didn't get it so now it has to
be terrible and my thing is it it's real
it's really
there's a a deeper uh through line to it
i just think when you spent a lot of
time
trying to defend
ten dollars for lips next gen lip
syncing tech
right
and you talked about devs doing things
uh and being compensated for it
which they should be
but now when there's a free update that
does way more than what you just paid
ten dollars for you you have to die on
that hill so you have to downplay
this um free update
and that's what it's really tied back to
it is that director's cut ten dollar
[ __ ] tax as i call it
and i call it the ps5 taxes
[ __ ]
turn turn on your ps5 play a game guys
you don't you know what's funny
when that was announced you should like
i was sitting there i'm like
loki king was right they paid their
making you pay for an update
who didn't say they're going to put a
quarter slot in the ps4 they're going to
be a card reader man you're just going
to go over there you're going to slide
it
you but but but but but really though
that's really what if you want to follow
the through line of why they were upset
about that they were not really upset
about that it was the
it was the the ten dollars that they
defended for an update so they they have
to downplay this one and that's really
what it is
yeah
it's like i said man like we just we
need to improve on all areas you know
we and and i agree with everborn we need
the same energy uh going towards
everything
there should be no reason why they're
trying to charge ten dollars like
if people would have gave the same
amount of energy for that psychonauts in
this hellblade that they that they gave
the the uh you know for
let me reverse that if people gave the
same amount of energy to that ps5
tax
like they did to this then i i feel like
it would have been different maybe that
could have fixed
because it to me it felt like the
majority of the playstation community
they was okay with what was going on
with that and and i wasn't i i felt like
it was it was a ridiculous tax and i
like
i felt like you should never be charged
just to use your own
systems
and that that's just my opinion if
you're if you're promoting these
features you should not charge your
consumers to use these features but
that's just me let's let's move on uh
everborn has stepped out for a couple
seconds let's move on to xbox
at gamescom
there has been
select times where xbox at gamescom has
been a big thing now they are having a
live stream and i think they had an
indie stream today correct
uh yeah
it was better than the last one but it
was not good because keep in mind i just
woke up an hour before the podcast i
worked 12-8
so
you know i don't know what's going on i
didn't watch it
i'm assuming it wasn't that good because
i didn't get a thousand tags what's
funny is i
we'll talk about this here in a second
because i do want to talk about this i
made a tweet that said
people always say sony doesn't have
money to buy this to buy that but then
they spend 1.2 billion dollars on on
crunchyroll so i'm like look sony got
money for every industry but the gaming
industry seems like i mean i was kind of
hype about the crunchyroll thing only
because i'm hoping
that they will include all the
crunchyroll content and my funimation
subscription all right so so let's
the game's gone the gamescom is the big
thing let's let's take it back a little
bit since since everborn's here let's
talk about this all right so
they bought
crunchyroll keep in mind they're already
on funimation i don't know how much they
spent on funimation does anyone off the
top of their head no idea all right so
how much did
sony buy fundamentation for
because that that that's important
uh sony funimation closes for 1.2
billion that might be the other one
1.175 acquisition
oh so did they buy them both
no no no they already own funimation
i think they want to merge them now
yeah so they're going to merge them
somebody in the chat said and i agree
with them the funimation app is garbage
it's terrible it is but
but the content that's what i'm there
for yeah yeah i need to i i don't have
crunchyroll have funimation and i i've
been told i chose the wrong force
uh uh do you like dubs
yes
well then funimation well see here here
i am with animes i gotta watch whatever
i started with
so like attack on titan i started that
with sub so i have to watch that sub the
rest of the time
dragon ball super i have to watch that
dub because goku sounds weird without
dubbed uh so
i don't know about that but i do also
watch it though so that
that is that is my opinion on the on the
matter like to me
they are putting a lot of money
in every industry but the gaming
industry and they put a lot of money in
the gaming industry but it's just like
the the stuff that you see microsoft
doing spending a billion here spending
seven billion here like
you see that with sony to a smaller
degree but it's not ever in the gaming
industry like it's like they feel they
they buy it uh they buy a studio when it
meets like this crazy criteria we've got
to work with them for 10 decades you
know they got to make 20 gains for us
like but it's just like to me
i do feel like sony is getting to the
point where they feel very comfortable
in the gaming industry and they don't
feel like they have to spend that money
to compete in the gaming industry but
why why wouldn't they feel that
comfortable everything they do
their fans
are
they're they defend them like left and
right like they can't do no wrong so
what does that tell
sony and let's be clear there's xbox
guys to do that on xbox i'm not saying
that i'm just saying by and large if you
if they're looking if they're if they're
looking at the the media landscape and
the social conversation
they're not doing anything wrong
that's it so so
why wouldn't they be [ __ ]
you know what i mean and to me i get
that in a hundred percent but it's just
like
i don't see
the disconnect when it comes to stuff
like that because i feel like
you should be able to critically run
your company without listening to these
fanboys you know what i'm saying like
it's just like they're looking at the
numbers too but but i i get that the
media the numbers and the fans all tell
them that but that always happens until
it isn't
you know what i'm saying and and and and
xbox was like that you know right after
the the 360 generation right like i'm
not saying that that's going to happen
to sony i'm just saying it is very
difficult
to change like you have to go to your
shareholders and say everything we're
doing right now is working it's bringing
you more money that it ever brought you
so now let's change that
right sony only changed for the ps4
because
they lost money on the ps3
i agree
microsoft's only doing the stuff because
they lost money on the xbox yeah
absolutely right so and that's the thing
with these companies it's very hard if
you have a winning formula to stop it
they're gonna they're going to uh you
know
ride this thing to the wheels fall off
and then
if when they can't anymore then they'll
be forced to change and we've seen it
with microsoft we've seen it with sony
we've seen it with nintendo that's just
how how this works now it could be
right because i look at i look at jim
ryan like uh a tim cook at apple
right
he's a money man right and he and and
tim cook is making apple more money than
steve jobs ever did
but he's he's still kind of uh
riding on the successes of of his
predecessor i think anyway
do you feel like there's ever going to
be a time i'm talking to you joe
do you feel like
sony will ever like kind of put this
type of money because to my knowledge
insomniac was a very cheap buy for them
it was like
a couple hundred mil
and house mark was probably even cheaper
than that
so like it was around the same actually
in the same ballpark
that if you account for inflation and
just the fact that um a lot of studios
are overvalued
right now because it's sort of this
buying season it's this buyer's market
even if they paid the same i feel like
it works out to a lot less than today's
money because like you can look at the
share price and what sony had in the
bank back then versus what they have now
and i think um in in
what 2018 money
um i i think that would have been a lot
different than today's money and that's
my opinion though so how do you feel
about all this um
joe like is that something that you
agree with that scenario
yeah i kind of do it's
it's interesting
what was the i'm sorry what's the what
was the full uh
context of the question though oh i was
just gonna ask you like do you uh would
you prefer them to like kind of dedicate
this kind of energy into the gaming
market because i do feel like sony
invests a lot into the gaming market but
here recently i feel like they they're
investing you know they bought
funimation for probably under a billion
they they bought crunchyroll for 1.2
billion like i don't i don't see
playstation making these kind of like
acquisitions in the gaming market maybe
it's because it's already so defined
but it's just like you already own
funimation that was a big part of the
end uh that market so now they own
crunchyroll so it's like maybe
anime right now because they're building
their anime portfolio is just more
important to them or maybe it's because
the gaming industry they have such a a
fine
you know heartbeat on that where they
know what's going on they don't have to
spend that kind of money so my question
to you is do you think that they should
dedicate some of that type of money into
the gaming industry to uh you know kind
of equal what microsoft's doing with all
the studios they've been buying because
i've said from the beginning like you
keep letting microsoft buy these studios
over and over again and you're not
trying to match the amount of numbers
that you have between them and your
competition sooner or later once these
studios start coming out games you're
going to see a huge difference in first
party titles coming out of both camps
right and
i think more or less they've been
wanting to buy certain studios but other
things
you know stuff like bethesda like sumo
digital to tencent and
like
i want to say i don't know if they were
close to any of the studios that
embracer's been buying but there's been
a lot there's been a lot of companies
have just been
going around snatching up studios left
and right so i think i think sony
wants to
but i also feel like they don't want to
overspend like you said like whenever it
comes to stuff like crunchyroll or
funimation
there's not like 50 or so different
uh anime streaming apps out there
there's only like you know
a couple like funimation control
so whenever they snatch those up they're
more or less grabbing you know the
important named ones that people
recognize
with all the other game studios i don't
really think they
really
i feel like they want to
but they're def but i feel like they've
gotten comfortable with buying studios
at a relatively cheap price like with
insomniac and house mark which house
park still weirds me out by that
purchase because
if fraternal only sold 560 000 copies
i gotta figure out what was the budget
that they spent for that game and why
did they spend the extra money on top of
that was it just to make sure that
housework didn't get
lost and at that point like what are
they gaining because they've they seemed
like they lost some
on
like fraternals uh launch so i don't
i never understood that myself but i
think when it comes to return i think it
was mainly just keeping it off the
market
uh because you know return regardless
how it sold it probably did
the majority of the games uh pre-gender
uh uh what's that term people always use
uh pre-generated content what is that
uh
procedural procedural generated content
a lot of that game is procedural so i
feel like data like that game would have
a little bit lower budget than a lot of
other games because like for the most
part they built an engine that's doing
all the work you know what i'm saying
yeah they didn't have to like go through
it and focus on anything like and if you
look at the game the game's great but
it's not right like highly detailed did
you ever play everborn
yeah i i played it got mad at it and
don't want it yeah so i mean
like nothing about that game like the
game just does something that's not been
done before so that's what was really
rolling off of i don't think yeah i
think there's a reason that wasn't done
before but we can talk about that in
another another thought yeah so you
don't fight the slander everborn i
really do
so you know that that's just my thing
when it comes to to the funimation thing
is like
look like i think the reason that they
spent that kind of money in the anime is
because of something like they want to
get their their hands into the anime
community and i saw some people in the
chat saying they got uh they got a
monopoly i don't think they got a
monopoly but they're they're coming damn
near close
uh yeah they are because netflix i think
they i think they have a monopoly in in
exporting anime to the us
but they don't have a monopoly on the
anime itself like they don't own
amniplex right they don't own the guys
who are making these things and shipping
their other places
this is just the the
the content delivery piece of it
but i don't think it's kind of weird
it's like does crunchyroll own any anime
well they were i don't think they do
maybe maybe of smackdown
um i know that they've wanted to make
like in-house like first party kind of
anime stuff like there was a lot of
different shows they were trying to get
off the ground but i have yet to see
any of those get made and
one of the things that kind of came to
mind whenever i saw that purchase goes
through is like okay that's cool but are
we at least gonna see the shows that
they've at least showed off because i
would have to go back oh oh gosh
netflix
oh [ __ ] oh well there you go
well there you go
look like to me
it's kind of weird they are i didn't
know they owned them
so like to me
otto owens major publishing outside of
funimation
i think they see i don't see a lot of
people correcting us when it comes to
like they own original stuff they have a
originals like god of high school
never heard of it and i'm not saying
that means anything i'm a casual anime
watcher but like to me
what the hell was 1.2 billion dollars
worth
to to own that market
it feels like to me they over overpaid
to make sure that the deal was done
and at the same time we can also look at
10 cent buying sumo and saying yeah i
don't think sumo's worth one point they
overpaid to make sure the deal was done
yeah ea just bought play demon who makes
like mobile games from wb games for what
was like a billion for something like
that so so to me
you needed to tell me that that sony
don't like overpaying for for studios
but they'll pay 1.2 billion for
crunchyroll
like it's just like man
it's weird yeah
you
where is that energy man if you would
have spent a fraction of that money you
could have bought a couple studios you
know be really good no but but to be
fair sony is also another huge arm is
sony pictures right like so they they
are in that that that business so that
part of the business makes sense it's
not like like the playstation division
acquired uh what do you call it so i i i
i
go ahead
i i was talking about morningly about
the distribution of the funds like
because at the end of the day it's all
going through sony it's just different
branches of their company
but like to me it feels like sony's like
look you guys are fine
we're gonna give you the money to
sustain all your studios to continue
your marketing
but it just feels like you don't need no
extra money
but we're gonna buy crunchyroll over
here for 1.2 billion dollars which to me
i just don't understand the cost of that
that that's like up there with a
minecraft purchase you know what i'm
saying like
like to me it's just like
they overpaid for that but when you know
you're constantly seeing them losing
bidding wars buying studios you know
what i'm saying everborn
i i mean i i get it i get it but you
know so they'll overpay for crunchyroll
but when it came to to outbidding uh
tencent for all those studios that
they're like oh that's as high as we're
going we're done
yeah but see those other studios don't
guarantee them i think what what what
crunch or crunchyroll
funimation uh
you know distribution monopoly
guarantees them and and and
this
listen
they have now this they have sony
doesn't have a streaming service outside
of funimation right so now that i have
these two streaming services which i'm
hoping they merge i think they will
and and that's that that is
i think this is like the the sony
pictures
side of things saying now we have our
own streaming service and it's it's it's
it's very
but they already have targeted streaming
services called fundamation
yeah but now that yeah but who was their
biggest competitor right
that was the thing and so now they don't
have that hurdle they that competition
is out of the way they own that market
and so when americans want to think
about anime and getting it legally
i have to put i have to put the
quotation figures up uh they they got to
go to sony right and and i think that is
that's worth it i think that pays for
itself inside of a couple of years
maybe less look
i i've seen people roll with that
they're doing it to to fight piracy i
don't i don't believe that that's the
dumbest thing ever oh
it doesn't matter what they do people
are still going pirates piracy is like
dinosaurs in jurassic park that's my
only point i see people in the chat say
attic your take is wrong look all i'm
saying is they already had a huge pulse
on the anime industry
they had funimation if they apparently
are aplex like that is literally a huge
portion of the anime industry the only
thing they didn't really own to like a
huge
above is is crunchyroll and netflix
so they already have this huge pie
just like they do on playstation but
they double dip on on the anime industry
but they don't really double dip on
and i get it i could be completely
overthinking this and i probably am but
to me it's like you're willing to over
spin for something like crunchyroll when
you already own a fundamental one you
could have spent a fraction of that
money making fundimation better but
instead of doing that they buy its
competition because they don't want to
compete in that room so it that's what
it me that's what i'm saying i think
what did you say
they don't want to compete in that realm
it doesn't feel like to me like it's
instead of investing that money into
funimation and making it better making
the video play better making the app
better making the ui more uh
friendly they just you know what let's
just buy crunchyroll who's the only
person right
how's the ui on crunchyroll because i
only have funimation
i i don't know man
all right so maybe maybe they wanted
their ui you you don't know but okay
here here is here is um
i'm gonna push back on you a little bit
at it
i think we just saw them
um buy house mark
and we saw them by king's favorite
studio ever that he never heard of
before this nexus right
um
and i think that they are going to be
buying more studios and i think
everyone's buying studios why i said
this on brap show i said this on boom
show right now money is cheap there are
fear of inflations there is uh
democratic leaders
uh democrat leaders in office right now
and usually that means corporate tax
rates will go up maybe they won't maybe
it doesn't mean that this time we'll see
but the the point is they have a lot of
money in the bank with 44 billion as of
their last um
uh earnings call
and or maybe it's 50 now i don't know
but the point is
that money
is just sitting there
and if they can make more money by
through an acquisition
they will
right then it will just be sitting there
earning interest and again fears of
inflation also um elevated price uh
stock price of everything the market is
super overinflated in terms of valuation
so
spend the money now before you get taxed
on it later or before it's worthless
after inflation
or before your stock price goes down
everyone is going to buy more things
this is just the latest thing so in the
in the last two months
they've bought two studios
and a monopoly on the anime industry and
then and i think they will buy more
studios it just depends on what's
available and i think you're going to
see the same thing from microsoft so
don't count them out yet i think they're
still investing in the gaming industry
well i didn't say they weren't i just
i'm saying like in the matter of a
couple years they they've bought two
giant glamorous such as funimation and
crunchyroll let me get this 10 super
chat from godzilla uh i'm pretty sure
that's how you want me to pronounce that
hashtag free mvc2 i'm pretty sure it's
marvel vs capcom 2. so i'm gonna make
sure that's part of it at this rate this
going i hope original anime ip holders
would just make their own streaming
service
like uh kudaru i definitely butchered
that with their manga cutting the middle
man
look it's not cheap to make streaming
services to that degree like unless it's
like
the anime ip holders owned a lot to
actually bring value to that streaming
service
it's probably always going to make more
sense for them to sell
you know their service to sell their
anime on another service and collect
money from it let me add another thing
i've brought up amniplex because they
make a lot of your favorite animes i
mean everyone's favorite animes right um
but i can tell you just from producing
some animes foreverborn
that the cost of that is about four
thousand dollars a minute and that is
like the sufferers price that's not the
big um
you know uh
dragon ball or or or
um
my hero academia price that's not that's
not i think that's the saga price the
last season of attack on titan was like
a hundred thousand dollars a minute or
something like that yeah that's what i'm
saying
right like the
the animation you saw for the everborn
kickstarter that is a rate at four
thousand dollars a minute so
it it is it is not cheap so manga
holders oftentimes
go and pitch their
stories to order not that i'm sure they
don't do it directly but somebody does
agents do this they pitch it to these uh
anime production houses and they you
know green light whether they want to
adapt it or not so it's it's if if if
you have the money to
okay you created your comic or your your
manga and then you somehow have the
money to produce your own anime without
having to go to
uh sony which is amiplex
then you know more power to you maybe
then you can afford your own um
streaming app but it's it's it's not
easy
all right so we got another 10 subtract
from godzilla
another thing not a fan of this is
because funimation
has a bit of a history editing original
scripts at times an example was
uh xvilla gillette i butchered that
bengali evangelion 3.0 and kyrie wasn't
a fan so it they oversaw the transition
themselves so he's pretty much saying
that
that fundamation
edited other people's animes
uh
i'm wondering if that if he knew about
that if that company knew that they were
doing that because they said it wasn't a
fan of it so i wonder if like they gave
them the ultimatum that yo we doing this
we don't give a [ __ ] what you have to
say like
but also don't forget funimation with
that uh dragon ball super [ __ ] don't
shoot he's black he's not black
wow
all right so
my friend sent me that clip and it's it
reminds me of ghost stories the english
dub it's so amazing so people
they want us to talk about gamescom
we'll talk about it now calm down chad
so everborn i'm gonna go to you first
questions i want to ask you
is
one
what do you expect at gamescom in terms
of this stream because they are having a
live stream it's interesting they
brought up bethesda and particularly
into this
so that's kind of interesting uh so my
question is do you think there's going
to be like any real big relevant
bethesda announcements and three
do you think we should be hyped for this
event
uh
no no and no
um uh be i i think we are gonna get
dates and that's the biggest thing and
if we can if we get at gamescom just
aside from bethesda for a second if we
get a date on the gunk if we get a date
on um crossfire x and things like that
i think that might be where we see it
yeah
yeah that's a good like
they end the stream with the
well maybe another a new campaign
trailer and it ends with the do we have
a is there a date on call of duty yet or
is that even coming out this
i feel like
i think they're waiting for that
honestly i think that's the one they're
waiting on for for
for for the right date to put it out
um so i honestly like they said there's
not gonna be any new game announcements
right aaron
aaron day one on green game pass
greenberg said that
so
um
you know just expect to see more of what
you already know about and i'm excited
for those games but that's kind of where
my hype level stops just getting more
info on what we already know which is
can i see some can i get a date on
crossfire x can i get game play on the
gunk um
what is is scorn still coming out what
about bright memory infinite
like
those are the things that i want to see
may and maybe we can see exomec i'm a
little excited for that but um i don't
expect to see anything new because they
literally said
uh they're not unless did that unless
that was a ruse
but i don't think so
so uh i'm not i'm not like hella excited
but i'll tell you what
when is the next sony event
i don't know
okay okay so uh
yeah you know what i'm not even going to
do it go ahead
so jose
man same question
i mean
everyone kind of took all my pics from
what i think we're going to be seeing
there you know stuff like scorn by
memory infinite
uh the gunk halos release date because
we actually do have to think about
uh let's see the date of the event will
be the 24th that's one day before
psychonauts so i can't imagine
that'll be in the event at all because
it's coming out literally the next day
will be really the point but
i don't know it just feels like
i i really do just want to see halo's
release date because
i
kind of don't think we're going to see
call of duty this year because of
everything going on in activision
so
yeah that's kind of all i got there well
so i do have a question for for the chat
and both of you fine gentlemen
do we see any halo campaign at gamescom
i think if we do see a release date
it's going to be
i don't think they would just drop a
release date that that wouldn't ver that
wouldn't work out too well like i think
that they would need
something to
like really
establish
that so i think the perfect way of doing
that
is to like
show a
to show like a update for
like the
the campaign like an updated campaign
trailer like nothing like even right
like real big just like just a small
little maybe one to two minute uh teaser
trailer of the campaign like a new
campaign trailer and then that's where
they drop at the end of it that's where
they drop the this is when this is
coming out
but what do you think joe
i mean what i'd like to see is just
literally uh
what you said about the campaign would
basically kind of the
worst case scenario the best cases there
would be like redoing like the entire
slice of the campaign they showed in
2020 but doing it all with how the game
looks now where it's going to be at at
launch
the way it's not the way they don't have
to always point towards that gameplay
that they showed last year because
people are still gonna just pause
remember craig's on screen so
yeah i think that you know
we're going to see some good stuff i
just
at the end of the day i hope that
you know
i hope that they they just show us
something like i think for the most part
what i would expect coming from this
event
is i think that you know they're not
going to show update like new games but
they might show
you know
see the next season of
of um
of grounded or
you know maybe show some teaser stuff
from
uh you know maybe an uh like i maybe see
these won't be there because they just
did one
but i don't know maybe there's like a
new thing coming out like a month and a
half to two that they show something for
c thieves like i i think that for the
most part like they
i think they might announce do some game
pass announcements throughout this maybe
nothing big
but just enough to like show you once
certain things are coming to certain
platforms
but as far as that like i don't really
expect much out of this
uh the biggest question i want is are
they gonna have an exo that's the
biggest question i wanna know
uh because i i don't feel like up until
now they haven't really had the kind of
content that they need to be able to do
something like an exo
but now i feel like they should be able
to do an xo
like and to be honest with you when they
did the exo
the year before uh that gamescom x go i
don't know if it was gamescom xo but i
was like why didn't remember they they
held on to hellblade
for
the video game awards so like part of me
feels like maybe that's their new thing
maybe they want to start showing more
stuff at the video game awards and i
have been told that they are going to be
at the video game awards in some
form or fashion well what do you feel
about that everborn do you think that
maybe they're holding on to a lot of
information just for the video game
awards
uh
i don't think it would be a lot of
information i think it would be like a a
big reveal so like one thing
right so there's other a lot of other
games that we kind of haven't
uh seen yet
so
i i think i think it it it'll be
something like that right because you
know we don't know what um
in exile is working on right
do we know um
today this is what i'm saying is they
still have a lot of unannounced games
but i don't think it's gonna be like you
know three or four big game
announcements or a studio acquisition or
something like that i and speaking of
studio
acquisitions i don't think we get any
from microsoft until at the earliest
next year
i agree i think for the most part
they're done with announcing studio
acquisitions i do think that they have
bought some studios but i don't think
that they're at the beginning
of those conversations nothing nothing
even really remotely legally has been
done so
yeah that's what i mean like but
but i don't know that they would have
closed any deals right because i think
if they do they have to notify just
cause like
they have to notify their shareholders
because there's some like regulations
around publicly um traded companies but
maybe it's only if both of them are
publicly traded so if it's not a
publicly traded company that they bought
maybe maybe they're they don't have to
notify everybody right away i'll tell
you what i don't like this is
small
rant i apologize
uh
xbox right
they have said
many times that um their end goal is not
council sales right
what their metric of success
is
it's um
monthly active users and game packs
and we got none of those numbers in
their latest um
um
shareholder call
right
and you can't have it both ways like you
can't say that um
council sales don't matter that's not
the metric for your success
what the metric is is is game pass and
monthly active users and then you still
don't give those numbers
right like that that to me i think is
something that needs to stop and i say
that as somebody who owns a
fair my fair share of microsoft stock
so i i don't like that and i think i
think more people should take them to
task on that because you actually own
microsoft stock everybody else is
talking about numbers and not only any
stock
i got in at 86. you can look at the
share price now
[Laughter]
it's just i always felt like the numbers
thing like i i've never really cared
about the numbers thing just like i've
never cared about the power thing
you know i've always been one of the
kind of person like dude i remember i
used to enjoy happy wars i don't know if
you guys remember that game but oh i i
played that on the 360. it was nice
so much so like and i was playing on the
xbox one at the beginning of the
generation so it's just like i got no
business
talking about anything about graphics
when i probably put more time into into
happy wars then some of you have played
games this year like did you ever play
happy dungeons yeah i played happy
dungeons too not as much i didn't really
like that one very much but
like happy wars man i
i used to play that day after day for
five six hours of time like all the time
every day i enjoyed that game uh i
remember having like all of the
the you know the skins and stuff for it
man i had played all the little side
activities or you would have to kill
like giant things at the end
yeah it was a fun time man and i kind of
i kind of miss those times i miss
microsoft investing
into those type of games and making sure
those games are good uh but you know
we'll have to see exactly what happens
but you know
one thing that i i've really wanted
gamescom is just like look man just give
me that give me that halo infinite
release date we need to know it it's
it's damn near in the middle of august
man but do you need to see can't anymore
from the campaign are you just good at
this point
the campaign's a bonus
really yeah because
i part of me don't expect to see it
jesus
but i'm just like i want to see it but
part of me is like
i've always been i love the the
the the core
i love the campaigns to halo i even
liked halo 5. i just felt like
they they could have executed it white
better but i felt honestly
halo 5 was good it's just how they
executed it was bad
i think even the execution was there i
think the problem is they didn't follow
up i think if you had a a halo 6 or some
kind of offshoot halo
uh in like 2016 2017 to because it kind
of ended on a weird cliffhanger
and
if they if they had followed up with it
it would have been in everybody's
consciousness and they could have tied
up the loose ends narratively that they
left like my opinion
i know why they did what they did with
the marketing they was trying to
completely throw you away from cortana
going crazy
it but it's just like come on man like
that was that was crazy like i i
remember getting so hyped at the end of
that campaign where cortana is looking
for the uh uh and i can't remember what
ship it was it was one of the [ __ ]
infinity yeah cortado is looking for
infinity and then you just see them
talking and then you hear cortana
talking over this the intercom she's
like i found you that she just teleports
a guardian out of nowhere they
hyperspace and she literally shuts down
all of the electricity on earth like i'm
like if that story would have continued
and they would have done it right it
would have been lit like cortana is off
the rails but now it just feels like
like it feels like they backpedaled like
i don't know what's going on like i
wanted to fight cortana and
because let me paint a picture for you i
think if they if they did what you said
right that's what comes out 2015 with
just focusing on master chief right with
the with the new engine new all of those
things master chief versus cortana
and then
no mention of lock and then you give
lock his own odst or reach style game
maybe even
make a game out of that nightfall movie
they made right
and then
that could have came out in 2016 2017
and then 2019
you got
you could put them against each other
but i think i think just introducing
that new character lock and putting them
up against chief who everybody grew up
with it wasn't smart nobody liked him
what should have happened is the tv show
should have came out
and like it did
uh first off it get apparent i guess it
didn't do well because we never got any
kind of remote sequel to that and then
after that there should have been a
lot game before five
yeah and then they built up into that
because what it should have done is when
you played his lock you should have been
okay with it but the fact is they didn't
build up that anticipation to even play
as long they just completely threw in
that where it's like you see lock
popping in i'm looking for these spartan
like like if if anything you should have
been the master chief running from luck
but you know people would have i i can
understand people having issues with
master chief running from anyone you
know what i'm saying like
it's like
lock i'm pretty sure is it
he is a um
a mach 5 isn't he
uh what do they call those
uh uh spartan two i think
no chief is a spartan two
long
so
it's just like
he was introduced in
i think spartan ops of halo 4 i believe
and yeah
you know actually don't even make a
spin-off game for halo 5. you could have
just done halo 5 spartan ops to continue
that story
throughout like they did on halo 4. i
don't know why they didn't do that it's
so weird
they had smart knobs for halo 4 but
didn't do anything similar for halo 5.
it's
stupid to me
i just felt like they like i've always
felt like 343 has been one of those
companies where
they make the game the community once
and not the game they want
and i think it's always blown up in
their face i think you see halo 4 halo 5
completely different game halo 5 to halo
infinite completely different game and i
feel like they do too much stuff off
camera they try to
they try to do what destiny does but not
as well as destiny
it's like look like at least
you know
people wouldn't even know the diadek
didn't even die in halo 5. he fell on
that planet and lived and then in a book
they killed him like people wouldn't
have even known that and i think that's
the issue the people that played halo 5
didn't even know that no halo 4 didn't
even know the diadek died in halo 4.
like that's crazy and to me
there shouldn't be scenarios like that
and i hope that they've changed it
i don't know we're not going to get too
too much into that but you know
i definitely understand look
at show has been a little
like little
left right center here today a lot of
stuff's been going on
uh
definitely want to thank joe and
everborn saga for coming on
uh hopefully
the industry will pick up in the next
couple weeks and there'll be like a lot
of we had a decent amount to talk about
today but it wasn't like juicy topics to
talk about but you know hopefully
with some of these triple-a products
some of the aaa games that come out some
of these good indies will come out um
next week we'll be able to talk about
hades because that will be i think that
comes out tomorrow actually
yeah the next week is 12 minutes
yeah
so you know part of the issue what's
going on right now is
there's just not a lot to talk about man
like last week on iop because
for those of you that don't know every
lord comes in with their own
topic on iron lure's podcast and they're
like adam what do you talk about i don't
know like
there ain't nothing to talk about
and nine times out of ten when it's when
it's really weak
on the news there's always games to fall
back on you know we could talk about
hellblade we could talk about new games
coming out we could talk about new games
coming to game pass like well i mean
that's kind of news but like you know
what i'm saying like at least new aaa's
coming out but there's never a scenario
where we know what's going on
but this time especially last week
there's nothing to talk about there's no
games coming out there's nothing
whatsoever to talk about so hopefully in
the next couple weeks it kind of picks
up but
joe where can people find you man what
do you got going on my voice is already
going out man my voice is going out well
first i want to say thank you for beyond
even if i was kind of pestering you a
little bit and ever born it was it was
great being on
the show with you um big fan of the
books by the way
and uh
i'm on twitter at joseph underscore f
gamer and i'm just writing for words of
gaming.net so
that's all i got going on that's what's
up everborn what is going on what is
that that juicy more content you got
going on man everyone sagada
that's where you can get all your hands
on all of the everborn books we got uh
we got ariel's adventure that's just
dropped we got um the ultimate edition
of prince of arcadia that has chapters
one and two and that hardcover
and we got chapter three and chapter
four is actually going to drop later
this month so be on the lookout for that
and because i got my branding in order
you can find me at everborn saga
everywhere check out the youtube channel
where we do the show every thursday at
eight on the rio where we talk about um
tv and movies and king usually comes to
join us whenever there's a movie that he
wants to talk about um and then on
saturday on que asante's channel we do
the gaming circle podcast where we we
you know we try to
try to have some uh
highbrow tech talk along with some
slander for whatever's going on in the
in the video game industry and
of course everyone on twitter xbox
playstation
um tick tock
you name it
instagram all that everyone saga
everywhere check it out definitely go
check out both of these people uh you
know uh i i definitely co-signed both of
them we'll be back next week iron lures
podcast is every sunday
i think uh
cog would kill me if i tell we are
having an industry guest on this week
i can't say who because cog would kill
me
if if i told you guys let me make sure
it's this week yes august the 15th
uh it does look like
the 12th of september is when we go to
the 11 a.m
time frame so um i'm gonna be hateful
every day
uh until we go back but i definitely
appreciate everyone coming through uh
this gave me